en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y los acompaño desde casa por la
pandemia de kobe 19 iniciamos hablando
de una problemática cada vez más común
relacionada con los síntomas prolongados
tras superar el coronavirus es decir con
el hobbit largo en una gran parte del
mundo aún no hay protocolos para
tratarlo en adultos y tampoco en niños
que en algunas ocasiones también
experimentan dolores de cabeza fatiga e
incluso dificultad respiratoria sin
embargo los expertos explican que el
mayor problema de los niños es que en
muchos casos no fueron diagnosticados
con kobe porque su sintomatología
durante el contagio fue leve
muchos de esos menores que experimentan
síntomas de kobe largo no tuvieron
acceso a una prueba en su momento cuando
se contagiaron
[Música]
así que sería poco acertado definir la
prevalencia del hobbit largo sin un
diagnóstico y sin la evidencia de que
tuvieron el virus en primer lugar
[Música]
en la ciudad británica de bristol se
realizará un estudio con más de 2.000
niños para determinar características
más claras del hobbit largo en menores y
que puedan acceder a tratamientos más
acertados tan pronto como sea posible
pues se ha comprobado que estos
padecimientos tienen no solo un impacto
físico sino también emocional en los
niños por ahora la solución que brindan
los expertos es controlar los síntomas
con tratamientos puntuales para ellos
y creo que hay que tratar los síntomas
como se haría con cualquiera que fuese
la fuente
james si habrá un momento en que se
tienda a asignar la causa de los
síntomas al covite pero
independientemente de si son causados
por el virus creo que por el momento es
necesario tratar síntomas como el dolor
articular o de cabeza o de estómago o
fiebre como si provinieran de otra causa
este dejar anillos de cruces cambiamos
de tema y ahora hablamos de tecnología
en muchas ocasiones hemos escuchado
hablar de vehículos autónomos pues ahora
un ingeniero que trabaja en huawei
desarrolló una bicicleta que no necesita
ser manejada se mantiene en pie por sí
sola e incluye novedosas características
como sensores de alta precisión cámaras
de reconocimiento y tecnología de
inteligencia artificial varias ciudades
ya la consideran como una solución de
movilidad sin contaminación veamos más
detalles
este podría ser el futuro de los viajes
en bicicleta es completamente autónoma
se mantiene en pie por sí misma y avanza
sin un conductor
detrás de este invento está un ingeniero
chino xi jinping se inspiró en una
fuerte caída para crear esta bicicleta
que mantiene el balance y evade
obstáculos
usando una cámara e inteligencia
artificial tiene dos motores grandes
junto con sensores y controles hay una
cámara en el manubrio acelerómetro
giroscopios y radares
también tiene una batería de litio que
dura entre 2 y 3 horas
los fabricantes cada vez se interesan
más en este tipo de vehículos y esta
tecnología no solo se limita a
bicicletas
esta es una moto desarrollada en el sur
de francia también está esta scooter en
inglaterra
por ahora este tipo de transporte está
en fase de pruebas sin embargo ya ha
llamado la atención de compañías de
transporte compartido en grandes
ciudades sea por eso que adaptado es
molesto para las compañías traer de
vuelta a las bicicletas al final del día
desde donde estaban con las autónomas
sería posible que regresaran solas así
que sería mucho más simple solo un viaje
utilizando oficial
el mercado potencial para esta
tecnología es gigante en 2020 80
millones de viajes se realizaron
mediante servicios de bicicletas
compartidas
y del futuro volvemos al pasado porque
el sur de argentina científicos y
estudiantes de paleontología y geología
de la universidad del comahue en la
provincia de neuquén descubrieron más de
160 huevos fosilizados de la era
mesozoica y encontramos todo un playón
con huevos de aves fósiles aves que son
caracterizadas por huevos de más o menos
de 5 a 7 centímetros si están en el
grupo de las aves en anchor ni test y
estamos hablando de 85 millones de años
desde hace un tiempo se están realizando
trabajos de remodelación en las
instalaciones de la universidad por lo
que un grupo de científicos ha venido
elaborando en paralelo para supervisar
la protección del patrimonio
mucha emoción la verdad porque no se
encuentran campus con tanto material
fosilífero en lo que es la argentina
y estamos en una situación privilegiada
por ser que el museo también se
encuentra dentro del campus
es doblemente fascinante poder
recolectar los fósiles y poder
trasladarlos al museo dentro de la
universidad y finalizamos en china donde
el mercado de los perros robóticos cada
vez tiene más demanda pues hoy hablamos
de alfaz de un divertido aparato que
utiliza sensores e inteligencia
artificial para escuchar y ver su
entorno y es calificado como el robot
más rápido del mundo pues corre a un
máximo de 15 kilómetros por hora a
muchos puede parecer les extraña la idea
de un perro robot sin embargo en sólo un
mes en el mercado fueron vendidos 1800
al paddock a precios de 2400 dólares sus
creadores aseguran que en un futuro
serán una herramienta clave para ayudar
a personas con discapacidad visual
llegamos al final de este episodio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía y
continúen con nosotros en france24
france24 puntocom
[Música]